In our previous video, we have taken a look
at the process of Pollination.
Can
you recall the process?
This process occurs in flowering plants.
the pollen
grains are transferred from the anther to
the stigma of the same or a different
flower.
We have also taken a look at the different
types of pollination.
Self-
Pollination and Cross Pollination.
Now let us see what exactly happens after
pollination.
The next and most
important step is that of Fertilisation!
Now, what is this process exactly?
Fertilisation is simply the process of fusion
of male and female gametes to give rise to
a new embryo.
Before understanding the process, let us understand
these terms which are
new for us!
Firstly let us get to know what gametes are!
Gametes are the specialised cells
which serve the function of reproduction.
we find these cells in organisms that
carry out sexual reproduction.
For now we only need to know that gametes
will be different in the males and females.
And sexual reproduction is where
the gametes from both male and female individual
will unite to give a zygote.
What is zygote?
It is the single cell structure formed from
the fusion of male
and female gametes.
This single cell further develops into an
embryo.
what is an embryo by the
way?
It is the structure that will further develop
into an organism.
So gametes
are the special cells, called sex cells present
in organisms that participate in
sexual reproduction.
Fusion of the two gametes, one from a male
and the
other from a female will give rise to a zygote
which will further develop into an
embryo.
This embryo grows and develops into the baby
organism.
In sexually reproducing organisms:
Male and female gametes  Sex cells
Fusion of gametes  Formation of zygote
Zygote  Embryo  Organism
(Note: Write develops above the arrows in
the last line, that zygote  Embryo
 Organism)
These were a few terms that we had to know.
Now let us get back to the fertilisation process
in plants.
Let us define it again.
It is the process of fusion of male and female
gametes to give rise to a new
embryo.
after pollination is successfully accomplished
how does fertilisation occur in
plants?
Let us zoom into this structure of a typical
Pistil, the female reproductive part
of the flower.
The Pollination process has caused the pollen
grains to safely
land on the stigma which is seen here!
For fertilisation to occur, the male gametes
need to reach this lower part of the
pistil, called ovary, where the female gamete
awaits it!
The female gamete or
the egg cell is present inside the ovary.
To form a zygote the female gamete
has to fuse with the male gamete!
Now how will this happen?
It is made possible by a structure called
the pollen tube!
This tube is formed
from the pollen grain itself.
The tube travels down the complete style and
ultimately reaches the ovary.
The tube carries along the male gamete that
is
safely taken to the ovary.
Now once the gamete reaches the ovary, the
two-fuse giving rise to the
formation of a single cell.
This is the zygote and the zygote will further
develop
into an embryo.
Zygote formation in plants marks the completion
of Fertilisation.
what happens next?
What will happen once fertilisation is successfully
accomplished? after fertilization the ovary
develops into a fruit and ovules
develop into seeds.
What is an ovule?
An ovule is a part of the female
reproductive system that will develop into
seeds after fertilisation.
This is all
we need to know for now.
We will get into the structure and functions
of ovule
in higher grades.
So getting back, the ovule forms the seed
which is nothing but a structure
containing the embryo inside it.
the baby plant!
A baby plant that is yet to
develop means it needs utmost protection.
That is why we have the seed!
A seed remains safe and guarded by a seed
coat which protects the inner
delicate parts and the embryo during unfavourable
conditions.
So how does a plant grow from this single
seed? when seeds are sown in the
soil, and when they achieve favourable conditions.
they germinate to give us a
new plantlet.
Now the next question is - how do seeds get
rooted every time in the soil?
Let
us get to know the concept of seed dispersal
and a few more interesting
concepts in the next video!